il n'aura jamais fait aussi beau à mes
fils --des après la tornade un soleil
radieux sur une ville en désolation qui
se réveille sous un amas de pierres car
ici presque rien n'a été épargné dès
l'aube le nettoyage commence ils sont
plusieurs à travailler d'arrache-pied
pour redonner un semblant de vie normale
à cette communauté de 10000 habitants
les équipes de secours continuent leurs
fouilles en espérant un miracle
on va partout avec nos chiens dit il on
veut s'assurer qu'elles soient jamais
oubliées cette maison c'est
littéralement effondré sur un enfant sa
mère a survécu et reçoit des soins
l'hôpital william le père et 100 mo il a
retrouvé son fils de 3 ans morts sous
les décombres
il ne veut pas être à la caméra son fils
appelé jalil il était dans les bras de
sa mère avec son petit frère lorsque le
toit s'est affaissé sur lui seulement
les voisins tentent du mieux qu'ils
peuvent apporter du réconfort
partout c'est la désolation ce bureau de
poste vieux de 100 ans n'aura pas pu non
plus
l'impact de la tornade a été dévastateur
dit heureusement ils n'avaient pas
d'employés on va déménager nos bureaux
dans la ville voisine il va falloir
reconstruire le restaurant steak race
est littéralement en miettes vendredi
soir les employés de ce restaurant
prêter leur party de noël le
propriétaire appris qu'ils avaient une
tornade qui se dirigeait vers la ville
il a demandé à tout le monde de quitter
les lieux vingt minutes après la tornade
s'est abattue ici
daniel canard est toujours pas en croire
ses yeux si lui et son frère n'avait pas
réagi rapidement world news le tournoi
quand j'ai su que la tornade à l'etrat
paix mais fier dit il j'ai appelé mon
frère il a réussi à renvoyer tout le
monde chez eux sept minutes avant que la
tornade s'abattent sur le restaurant
à quelques kilomètres de là lusine de
bougies n'a pas eu la même chance on
continue à compter les morts 110
employés travaillent et toujours lorsque
la tornade a frappé oui
on est résilié le propriétaire on va
essayer de nous en sortir du mieux qu'on
peut on va tout faire pour aider nos
employés ajoutent ils la tornade aura
détruit en quelques heures tout une
ville qui prendra certainement des
années à s'en remettre il s'est abonné
guergis radio canada méfiante kentucky